翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Naoko Hirami
早速ですが最初に一つ
みなさんにお願い事があります
今から30秒間
目をつぶっていただいてもよろしいでしょうか
最初に瞑想をします
何も考える必要はありません
では どうぞ
（瞑想中）
（瞑想終わり）
はい ありがとうございます
目を開けてください
今日は 今みなさんの頭の中に
浮かんでいた雑念を
一瞬で消してしまうアイデアを紹介します
そのアイデアを実践すれば
普段から僕たちの頭の中に浮かんでくる
言葉や考えなどの雑念は
一瞬で消え去って
そしてより 今という時間を
大切にできるようになります
もし今何も考えずにいられた
全く無の状態で いられたという
まるでお釈迦さまのような方が
いらっしゃったらですね
僕のプレゼンの間は
寝ていただいても大丈夫です
気持ちよさそうなソファもありますので
でも逆に 普段から考えたくないけど
色々なことを考えてしまうとか
悩み事とかあると その事で
もう頭がいっぱいになってしまって
頭が堂々巡り 言葉が堂々巡り
っていうことがある人は
きっと今日お伝えするアイデアは
お役に立てると思います
そのアイデアはとてもシンプルです
それは
『ジブリッシュ』と呼ばれる
ちんぷんかんぷん語
でたらめ言葉です
口から出まかせの
全く意味のない言葉を話します
ふざけたアイデアだと
思われるかもしれませんが
でも実はこの意味のないことに
意味があるんです
そのことについては
今日実際に聞いていただいたり
話していただいたりしたらですね
分かっていただけると思います
最後 今日はみなさんにも
実際にジブリッシュを話していただく
時間を設けているので
楽しみにしていただけたらと思います
その前にまず
どんな風に実際ジブリッシュを話すのか
また 日常でどんな風に活用できるか
それから
どんな風に遊んで楽しめるか
そういうのを まず
見て聞いて楽しんでいただけたらと思います
（ジブリッシュ）
これです
（笑）（拍手）
今 僕は意味のない言葉を話していました
でも普段 僕たちは意味のある言葉に
囲まれて生きています
特に今 情報化社会[で]
時間があったら スマホ パソコン
LINE Facebook インターネット
いつでも言葉が溢れています
とっても便利なんですけど
でも言葉があるということは
常に僕たちの脳は
その意味を理解しようと勝手に働きます
これ 「怒る」って読んだ人いないですよね
[笑]
僕たちの脳は勝手に読むんですよ
言葉があったら
勝手にその意味を理解しようと動きます
ということは これだけ情報が
溢れている社会に生きているということは
常に脳は働かないといけません
だから もしかしたら 僕たちの脳は
少しお疲れ気味かもしれません
ジブリッシュを話すということは
その脳を休ませることにつながります
（ジブリッシュ）
と 話しながら何かを考えるって
絶対できないですよね
そうなんです ジブリッシュを話すと
逆に全く何も考えられなくなってしまうんです
さあ どんどん脳みそほぐしていきましょう
今度は数字でジブリッシュです
数字で会話をします
ただ今日は 今登壇者一人なので
劇のような形でお見せしたいと思います
「数字で告白」
花束をプレゼントしてみたいと思います
34　59
65　51　295　33
6億5,003（笑）
くだらないですよね（笑）
（拍手）
このくだならなさが このジブリッシュの
魅力のまた大切なポイントなんですよね
どんどんいきます
ではこのジブリッシュを
普段僕はどんな風に活用してるのか
というのをここで紹介したいと思います
実はですね このジブリッシュ
ストレス発散に使えます
感情を出すことができるんですね
これを使うと
ですからですね
生きていると色んなことあるじゃないですか
辛いこととか そういう時に
こうやって出すんですよ
（ジブリッシュ）
いや　これほんとですよ
ほんとにやるんですよ（笑）
やると まず一人でやってる自分に笑えます
（笑）
で 次は変わります
次は普通にすっきりしだします
（ジブリッシュ）
で ３段階目
そもそもあまり感じなくなりました
抑圧感情というものを
みなさんも普段
思いっきり泣いたり笑ったりしたら
すっきりしたという経験はないでしょうか
あれを心理学では「カタルシス」
「感情の浄化作用」と呼びます
ジブリッシュは 実はその感情の浄化作用を
気軽に行うことができるんですね
逆にそれができないと
自分の中に抑圧感情というものを
溜めて溜めて溜めて溜めて溜めて
溜め込んでしまって
いつか
「もういやだー！」
となって周りの人に当たってしまったり
物に当たってしまったりということになります
みなさんも 普段生活してる中で
急に誰かに当たられたこととかないですか
当たる方かもしれないですけど
きっとそういう経験ってあるかなと思います
まだそうやって出せたらいいんですけど
ほんとに出せないとですね
自分の中にまた溜め込んで溜め込んで
溜め込んで溜め込んで溜め込んで溜め込んで
それが身体の症状として病気として
出てきてしまうということもあります
でも 安心してください
ジブリッシュを話すことができれば
いつでも 好きな時に
小出しに または一気に
自由に出すことができるんです
実際こうやって出してしまうと
案外すっきり 頭もすっきりするものです
それから 案外困ってた物事自体も
感情を出してしまうと
意外と すんなり受け入れられてる自分が
いたりもします
今日はこのジブリッシュをみなさんにも
ぜひ体感していただけたらと思います
で 今からですね
立ち上がっていただきたいと思うんですが
その前に
一つお決まり事をお伝えしたいと思います
それはですね 日本語及び意味のある言葉を
使わないということです
日本語を使うと
すぐにまた理性的な論理的な思考
意味をすぐ考える頭に戻ってしまいます
そうするとそれがブロックになってしまって
すぐまた考える脳に戻ってしまうので
今日は関西ですが ツッコミもなしで
お願いできたらと思います
もうすでに
ツッコミどころ満載だと思うんですけど
ということで じゃあ皆さん
一緒にまずは体験してみたいと思います
では 立ち上がってください
立ち上がっていただくのも意味があります
なぜかというと
身体と心というのは連携してるからです
身体が硬直してると心も硬直します
でも身体を動かしていけば
心も動いていきます
ということで 皆さん
身体ちょっとほぐしてくださいね
自由に動かしてください
これから３段階ステップを踏んでいきます
一つ目が 口パクでジブリッシュ
二つ目が 小声でジブリッシュ
そして三つ目が 普通にジブリッシュです
ますは 口パクからやっていきます
顔の体操だと思ってください
ウォーミングアップですね
顔の体操 とにかくまず口を
色んな形に動かします
これに手を添えると
まるで喋っているかのようになります
じゃあ みなさん
まずは口パクで一緒にですね
ちょっと体操と思って
一斉にこっち向いてやってください
横の人と目が合うと
恥ずかしいと思います（笑）
お気持ち察してますからね
じゃあ こっちを見て一斉にいきますね
顔の体操です
いきますよ せーの
（口パクでジブリッシュ）
色んな形でとにかく筋肉の体操と思って
動かしてください
（口パクでジブリッシュ）
手を大胆に動かします
あ いいですね いい感じ
そんな感じ
（口パクでジブリッシュ）
はい ありがとうございます
これが一つ目
次が小声でジブリッシュです（笑）
みなさん 初めてだと思いますので
ちょっとどんな風に出せるか試すような感じで
聞こえるか聞こえないかぐらい
（小声でジブリッシュ）
（笑）
いいでしょ このくだらなさが（笑）
じゃあ みなさん試してみてね
いいですか 横見ちゃだめですよ
こっち見てくださいね（笑）
はい いきますよ　せーの
（小声でジブリッシュ）
くだらなくて笑ってる人いますね（笑）
はい ありがとうございます
大丈夫です
みなさん大分いい感じになってきました
もう少しね 表情をまた動かして
表情と手と動かしていくと
より面白味が出てきますね
では そのまま今度は普通に
ジブリッシュを出してみてください
今までと一緒です
横の人は見ないでね
勢いよく出してみてください
いきますね
はい ではいきましょう
せーの
（ジブリッシュ）
はい ありがとうございます
いや いいですねみなさん
素晴らしい素晴らしい
（拍手）
みなさんが拍手をするということは
もうちょっとしたいのかな
（笑）
せっかくなんで
これね 言葉の壁を超えるんです
TEDのコンセプト
「交流」も入ってましたよね
周りの人とこれで会話をしてみましょう
これはポイントは
話してる感じ でいいです
聞いてる感じ でいいです
何言ってるかわからないですから
ではちょっと周りの人[を]ちらちら見ながら
ちょっと会話を楽しんでみてください
ではいきましょう
せーの
（会場全体 ジブリッシュ）
（拍手）
いや 素晴らしいです ほんとに
もしかしたら今苦手だったっていう人
それから ちょっと色々まだ考えてしまった
という人がいるかもしれないです
安心してください
それが普通なんで（笑）
こっちが異常みたいなね
でも異常ではないですよ
言葉を覚えるまでは
みなさん同じことしてましたから
苦手だったという人も安心してください
苦手だったという人でも 回数を重ねるうちに
ハマっていったという人も
いっぱい会ってきたんです 今まで
僕は普段「のびー」と
呼ばれることが多いのですが
「のびー 私もうジブリッシュ
やめられないわ」（笑）[と話す人に]
いっぱい会ってきたんで
何か感じるものがあったり
引っかかるものがあったら
家で自主練をしていただけたらと思います（笑）
今日僕がお伝えしたアイデアというのは
一瞬で雑念を消し去ってしまう方法
としての『ジブリッシュ』でした
しかし 誤解しないでください
「考えなくていい」 とは言っていません
僕が考える雑念がある状態というのは
考えなくていいことを考えている状態です
生きてたら色んなことあります
辛いこと 悲しいこと 過去の後悔
将来の不安 色んなことが湧いてきます
それは その都度真剣に
考えたらいいと思うんですけど
ただ それをいつまでも
ダラダラと引きずって考えたり
いつまでも深刻に考えすぎたりして
いつも意識が過去とか未来にいってたら
それってすごいもったいないなって思うんです
だって生きてるのは「今」ですから
みなさんはもうジブリッシュを
話すことができます
頭が雑念でいっぱいだったら
いつでも出してください
心がモヤモヤしてたら
そして 本当に今 自分が考えるべきこと
本当に今 自分が大切にしたいって
本当に今 感じることを
大切にしてください
それが今を大切にするということ
今を生きるということだと思います
（ジブリッシュ）
ありがとうございました
（拍手）